yeah I used to work in post-production I
was uh I was the post PA I used to bring
like the editors food and coffee and
stuff and I was I worked on a show where
they put a bunch of celebrities and put
them in a house so we had Corey Feldman
was in this room and he got married oh
and so I was so bummed out when I
realized reality shows were fake
I was like 20. I was like wait what
there was this thing of Corey Feldman
and he was getting uh he was crying
laughs
and he was going like I'm just I'm just
so worried about everything that's going
on with me right now and I I don't know
what's gonna happen and I'm really
worried and like you're the producer off
camera go that was great Corey can you
just say this weekend because that's
when the English what yeah no problem
[Applause]
no